marine le pen déambulant dans les
jardins du château de villandry sans
doute l'une des images que l'on
retiendra de ces élections régionales en
centre val de loire
à dix jours du premier tour la chef du
rassemblement national est venu soutenir
son candidat aleksandar nikolic sur
place on retrouve romain des deux villes
avec rémy carton
marine le pen au château de villandry
pour soutenir le candidat et rennes aux
régionales aleksandar nico leach c'est
un peu une interférence des campagnes
électorales à moins d'un an de
l'élection présidentielle où il ne fait
aucun doute qu'elle sera candidate à la
présidentielle est une élection tout à
fait particulière qui ne répond pas du
tout à la même logique que les élections
territoriales mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que l'on peut mesurer la dynamique qui
aujourd'hui accompagne les idées du
rassemblement national accompagne les
candidats du rassemblement national
la tête de liste rassemblement national
en région centre val de loire ne s'en
cache pas il compte bien profiter d'une
dynamique nationale autour de thèmes or
des compétences de la région comme par
exemple la sécurité en centre val de
loire la question du manque de soignants
est une priorité pour les années à venir
la majorité actuelle s'est résolue à
rendre des médecins salariés
mais pour le leader et rennes ça ne
marche pas sur le papier c'est très bien
de construire des maisons emploi
disciplinaire mais on a plein d'exemples
de maisons aujourd'hui qui sont vides
donc c'est très bien mais il va falloir
faire en sorte que le territoire soit
attractif pour mettre des médecins dans
les maisons pluridisciplinaires par
l'attractivité comme je le dis et ou
sinon par le recrutement de médecins
aleksandar nikolic le répète à l'envi il
veut que sa candidature soit la seule
alternative à la liste de françois
bonneau le président sortant il y a 6
ans le rassemblement national avait vire
en tête au premier tour
au second tour il avait fini troisième